-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Before we begin, I just want to
give a shout-out to our show's
number-one fan, the President
of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As you --
[ Laughter ]
As you may have heard
last night, the President
of the United States
went after me on Twitter.
So Melania, if you're watching,
I don't think your anti-bullying
campaign is working.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's not working.
When I saw that Trump insulted
me on Twitter, I was going to
tweet back immediately,
but I thought I had
more important things to do.
Then I thought, wait, shouldn't
he have more important things
to do?
He's the President of the --
What are you doing?
You're the President!
Why's he tweeting at me?
But this is real -- it's a real
tweet from the President.
He wrote, "@Jimmyfallon
is now whimpering to all
that he did the
famous hair show with me,
where he seriously
messed up my hair."
And that "He would have done it
differently because it is said
to have humanized me.
He is taking heat.
He called and said,
'monster ratings.'
Be a man, Jimmy!"
[ Laughter ]
It's real.
It's crazy, the President went
after me on Twitter.
It's pretty much the only thing
I have in common with
NFL players.
I mean, it's the only thing.
I have nothing else.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, in response,
I made a donation
in Trump's name to the Refugee
and Immigrants Center
for Education
and Legal Services.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Refugee and Immigrant Center
for Education and
Legal Services, or "RAICES."
When Trump heard that
he was like, [ As Trump ]
"I love 'raices,'
they're my favorite
peanut butter cup.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's no wrong way
to eat a 'raices.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Let's get
to some real news here.
A new poll found that 58% of
Americans think President Trump
is intelligent.
In response, Trump was like,
[ As Trump ] "Okay,
what do the other 58% say?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Today at
the White House, Trump met
with the King and Queen of
Jordan, which got awkward when
Trump thanked the King of Jordan
for giving us Michael.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is a big story --
this weekend,
White House Press Secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
was kicked out of
a restaurant in Virginia.
Turns out her server asked her
what she wanted as an appetizer
and out of habit,
she refused to answer.
And --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Actually, the President
responded on Twitter
to the restaurant, which is
called The Red Hen.
Again, this is real.
Trump tweeted,
"The Red Hen Restaurant
should focus more on cleaning
its filthy canopies, doors,
and windows (badly needs
a paint job) rather than
refusing to serve a fine person
like Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
I always had a rule,
if a restaurant is dirty
on the outside,
it is dirty on the inside!"
So if you ever read
a Yelp review and thought,
"Who's got the time
to write this?"
the answer is, the President
of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's writing Yelp reviews!
[ Laughter ]
This is cool here.
Meghan Markle has become
the first member of
the royal family to be nominated
for a "Teen Choice" award.
And not to be outdone,
the Queen has announced
she's doing an album with Migos.
It'll be cool.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, that's good.
-Should be fun.
Finally, I want to say congrats
to "fixer upper" hosts
Chip and Joanna Gaines, who just
welcomed a new baby boy.
Isn't that great?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They are thrilled and said that
after a few weeks of raising
him, they'll flip him
for an even better baby.
We have a great show tonight!
Give it up for
The Roots, everybody!
♪♪